ELIJAH BLAKE: All
right, welcome back.
We're going to be going over
Redux and network requests,
so connecting our
Redux-Sagas to the backend so
that not only our Redux
store gets updated,
but our backend
databases as well.
And we'll just recap quickly
on our Redux setup in this app.
So for those of you that
have been following along
with this lecture
set, we had this form
that we could put data in.
And let's give it
some data there.
Submit, it refreshes
our form data.
Then we can go down here, with
this button, to view the list.
And actually before, it
was only a single instance.
Off camera here,
off the recording,
I made it so that this will
also append multiple instances
of the user class, which is
going to help it work well
with our database since we'll
have multiple rows in our table.
So if we submit that, now we've
got two items in our list.
And it'll keep going.
This is a scroll view,
it'll go for as long
as we add data there.
And then let's look
at the code for that.
Here we've got our slice.
And I've made a
few changes here.
So addFormData will
take the current list
and it will push a new
instance or the new payload,
whatever new user we're
adding there, to the list.
So instead of doing formData
equals action.payload,
we're doing formdata.push
since this is a list.
Before it was just
a single object,
but now it'll hold
a list of objects
so that that works
as a list instead
of only holding a single
object's worth of data there.
And then in our
DisplayUserData, here we
have our Selector that pulls the
form data out of our user state.
And then that is a array.
So we can array dot map.
Map is a fun--
I don't remember if Python has
an equivalent list function,
but I'm sure they do.
Basically, it just maps over.
For every item in the list,
we're going to return,
and we're returning a card.
So instead of returning
like a value, like a number,
or some string, our return
value is this entire set
of JSX, this component.
That's why we see--
well, we did.
It must have refreshed--
but multiple card
components there.
But we want to update this
so that we not only store
our data here in our
Redux slice, in our store,
but we also want to
persist it to a database
so that we have something--
so the data can live beyond
a single user session list.
Like we see here, if I go back
to the list, the list is empty.
Any time you refresh your
browser, or spin down,
spin back up your Metro
instance, this list,
all the Redux store
data, will be reset
back to your initial state.
In this case, that's
an empty list.
So we're going to persist
it to a database here.
So the first thing that
we're going to do with that
is, we'll want to make sure
that our backend can be spun up
as well.
So I've got our Metro server
running for the Expo app.
And I'll exit out of that.
So here in data5570 folder,
I have the Expo app folder.
And if I cd out
of that, I've got
the Expo app, my Django app,
and then my virtual environment.
So I'm going to-- in
order to spin up Django,
I'm going to source the
virtual environment,
source myvenv/bin/activate.
And it's been a
minute since we've
done this so if you've
forgotten, we're refreshing
right now.
Source that.
That adds your virtual
environment info to your path.
In this case, that's all the
items we installed with pip,
so that includes
Django REST framework.
Now that we have that
active, we should
be able to cd into the
Django project, whatever
you called your project.
And then where manage.py
is, we should be able to--
python3 manage.py runserver.
And if you wanted to
expose to external traffic,
we were doing 0.0.0.0 or 8000.
And that way, you can
access it from your browser.
So we've got the
Django server up.
And then I'm running it here.
Oh, yeah, right, I don't
have a default path defined.
So in my Django project, my
Django app, in my urls.py,
I'm expecting traffic at
slash api slash users.
So I go to api/users, and
there's my Django REST framework
interface.
And again, I got that path
from inside of my app.
I have users.
But before that, inside of the
project, there's a urls.py,
and I added api there.
So I need api/users.
OK, so we've verified
that the API endpoint is
up with Django REST framework.
If you used Django
REST framework--
and how do if you used
Django REST framework?
In your views.py, you
would import rest_framework
and create your GET
and POST handlers
with your rest_framework.
And you can just get your
JNI to make yours for you.
If you have REST
framework installed,
you just install that with pip.
And then if you used Django REST
framework to set up your POST
and GET endpoint, you should
be able to get this interface.
And you message me or
review the Django lectures,
if you have questions on getting
caught back up with that.
But we've verified that our
Django backend is running,
the endpoint is available,
so I'm going to open--
I'm going to leave this running
and then open up a new terminal.
And if you're on your
VS Code interface,
you should be able
to-- up at the top,
there's a hamburger menu where
you can select and then open
a new terminal.
You can have multiple
terminals open in your VS Code.
I just have my system terminal
here, so I opened up a new app.
And then in this one, I'm going
to cd out of the Django project
and then into Expo app.
I've got this terminal
running with the Django app.
This one is inside
of the Expo app.
It can npm start there.
Then you should be able to
hit W and pop that open.
Django is running on port
8000 because I told it to.
And Expo runs on
port 8081 by default.
OK, so they're both
running side by side,
but they're not
talking to each other.
But Django is ready to accept
traffic at our endpoint.
That's the way we set
it up in our homework.
So now, we just need
to get Expo to point
to our backend instance.
So the way we're going
to do that is I'm
going to open my userSlice here.
And this is where we set up our
Redux slice to handle updates
to our list of user data.
Yours may be a list of
customer data or any other data
that you're storing in Redux.
I'm going to go ahead and just
copy that, pop over here to GPT,
and then I can just get
a new window going there.
And let's remember
the context here.
If you have got your
GPT running inline,
then it can pull the
context from the files
that it has in its parameters.
If you don't, you're prompting
in a browser like this,
there are a few things that
you want to keep in mind
so that it knows what
it's looking for.
"I'm using--" or let's see, "I
have an expo app using redux
slices--" And this terminology
here, Redux slices,
is important.
As we saw with our
Redux homework,
Redux slices are important
because that's the way we set up
our Redux slice.
Without using a slice like
this from Redux toolkit,
you have to set up
your actions manually.
So you have to define
those yourself.
But we've used the
slices toolkit,
so that simplifies
our code a little bit.
So "I have an expo app
using redux slices.
I have a django server accepting
traffic at--" Mine is localhost
right now.
Yours would be the IP
address of your EC2 instance.
So just grab your IP address,
and remember it's port
8000, and then you're going
to need your whole path
to the endpoint.
Mine is api/users.
And again, just to make sure
we know how to get that,
open up Django--
or Django project, open that up.
There's an app folder.
And then there's the
project logic in here.
So next to your settings.py,
there's a urls.py.
This is where your
admin site is set up
if you went that route,
which is not necessary.
But then I also
included api_app.urls.
And that is this, the exact
same spelling, api_app.urls.
I included that to append
onto the API endpoint.
So if I pop open api_app,
then open the urls.py here,
then I have users.
And this endpoint is the one I'm
using for GET and POST requests.
There's one here that is users.
And then an ID, that's
for PUT or DELETE,
so if I'm going to delete
a specific instance.
But in this case, we're just
worried about GET and POST.
So I have the users
endpoint here.
So again, that's from
this urls.py api,
and then append on to that
whatever the path is inside
of urls.py.
So I'm "accepting traffic at
localhost:8000/api/users."
Now it knows where to look.
And I'm going to
give it my models.py,
just so it knows what format
I'm expecting on the backend
because it's case
sensitive, and it'll
need to match when it
gets sent to the backend.
So if I pop open
models.py, these
are all of the items
it's going to look for,
or the keys in my user model.
So I'm just going to copy all
that and paste that in there.
And then "This is my redux
slice:" Keep that open.
UserSlice, I'm
going to copy that.
So now, it's got the
context it needs.
We know we're working in an
Expo app with Redux slices.
I've got a Django
server, and it knows
where we're expecting traffic.
This is my models.py.
Then I gave it my
Redux slice as well.
"I want to edit the redux slice
to push and pull data from
the django server."
I think that's all we need.
Because what this
is going to do,
they're going to-- we
have the reducers here,
where they're editing users, or
we're adding users, or I guess,
in this case, we
can remove them.
I am not using the remove or
update functionality in my app
anywhere, but
we've got it there.
But instead of having
reducers, we're
going to use this thing
called extraReducers
to handle asynchronous updates.
Let's go ahead and
start with that.
OK, so it's breaking
this down here.
Use Redux Thunks, and
it's a funny word,
but the reason
they're using thunks
is because of Redux toolkit.
Thunks is something we
get out of Redux toolkit
as well, to handle API requests.
So we're going to go ahead
and modify the slice,
and go ahead and set up this
to fetch data from the backend.
Let's go ahead and
update that slice
and see what we've got here.
OK, so thunks for
the async operations.
Oh, and it's giving us a
Base API URL constant here.
That's good, because whenever
you spin down and spin back up,
your EC2 instance, your
IP address changes, right?
So in a development
environment, that's
fine that your IP
address will change.
You'll just have to make sure--
if you set it up this way,
where you have your API_URL
in a constant like this,
or in a variable, you could
just go ahead and change your IP
address right there.
And then the rest of
the code stays the same.
You only have one
place to update it.
In a production
setting, the IP would
be pulled from an environment
variable in your EC2 instance,
or wherever you have
your app deployed.
So our fetchUsers, this
is going to pull down--
so this is going to fire our GET
request, to get the list of data
from our Django backend.
So "fetch" is a
JavaScript function.
It's just built into JavaScript.
JavaScript was made for web
applications originally,
so it handles network requests
and asynchronous functionality
pretty well out of the box.
This "await" keyword
is important.
So this is this async
for the function.
That just makes sure
that even though fetch
is going to take an
unknown amount of time,
this function will
still execute--
it'll run as if it were
executing line by line.
And then if this response
from our GET request
comes back with a response
other than OK, in other words,
the request was bad
or there was an error,
then it's going to go ahead
and just throw an error.
That's just some super
simple error handling there.
And then it'll return the
JSON from the response
of that fetch request.
So that's the GET request
to our Django backend.
CreateUser, we're going to
actually have to specify.
So fetch, by default, is
going to use the GET method.
Here, we're hitting
the same endpoint,
but we're doing a POST
request and adding
our body, which is just all
of our user data in our--
or it's the new user data that
we submitted with our form.
And then the same, we've just
got some simple error handling
there.
And then we've got an update.
So this is a PUT request.
This will update an existing row
in our database on the backend.
We just pass the user data
for that endpoint as well,
and it's passing the ID.
So the URL that we're using
here, these backticks,
and the dollar sign,
and brackets here, this
is a-- what's it called--
a string composition
in JavaScript.
So this is just getting our
URL, and then slash, and then
the ID of the user that we
want to change or update.
Then our DELETE will-- yeah,
it's doing the same thing.
And that will map to our--
we look at our models--
or no, our urls.py.
Again, we have users,
endpoints for GET and POST.
And then for our PUT or
DELETE, we have users slash,
and then an ID that
matches what we're
doing here with our DELETE
and our PUT endpoints.
And then our Initial
State is changed again.
So we used to just have
a list of form data,
but now we've also got
a status and an error.
And those can help us track the
state of our network requests
as it's going.
So let's go ahead and look at
what happened to our reducers.
So reducers is now empty.
And that's because
these reducers are only
for synchronous operations,
meaning they're going to happen.
They're only happening
locally on our device,
and they don't have to
wait on any [AUDIO OUT].
ExtraReducers do have
to wait on things.
They can handle
asynchronous updates.
And then they just
have these cases,
where it listens
to these events.
So pending, fulfilled, rejected.
Pending is when you've
started to add a user using
the-- this is going to be
using the createUser endpoint,
I believe.
This is for fetch.
Yes, fetchUsers is
pending, meaning,
we've started to fetch
users from the backend.
Fulfilled means it succeeded.
And in that case, we're
going to grab our--
we're going to set our
network request as succeeded
and update our user
list to whatever
the backend returned for us.
And then again, if
it rejected, we're
going to fail, and update
the error part of our state,
so that we can read
that if we want to.
It's somewhere in the app.
And then we've got
cases for createUser.
It looks like this createUser
case doesn't have-- the pop up
is annoying-- it doesn't
have one for pending,
but we could put
one if we wanted to.
I guess it just assumed
we didn't need one.
And maybe, we don't.
For example, on our frontend,
if we hit the Submit button,
do we want to have to show the
user that it's still submitting
or still updating, or do we
want it to just continue and act
like it happened instantly?
In this case, it's going to
act like it happened instantly.
So we're just submitting
that data to the backend.
If it succeeded,
then we're going
to take whatever that data
was and add it to our list
so that we have a local copy of
that new user data in our list
as well.
So say, we already had users in
this list, it's just going to--
after we succeed pushing
it to the backend,
and the backend says, yeah,
I got you, I got that data,
then we're going to add it
to our local copy as well.
So we've got one.
We don't have to pull a new
list, we've already got it here.
And then we've
got a success case
for updateUser and deleteUser.
We could tell the
GPT to do this,
or we could do it ourselves.
But if we wanted to add
a case-- for example,
let's say, we had
our UI here, and we
wanted to show the user
that, hey, submitting
that user data
failed-- you wanted
to show a toast, or some sort
of message, a notification,
that this form failed,
then what we would do
is add a new case here for
createUsers.rejected, kind
of like they did
here on the fetch.
And then we could
track the error message
and then display that
to the [AUDIO OUT].
I think, in this case,
we don't need it.
But, just so you
know, if you did,
that's where you would do it.
You would add a case here, make
sure you had a rejected case
so that your user interface
could respond to that.
But I think that's about--
at least, that covers what's
going on in this file.
And then we're going to need to
update our form because here,
in index.jsx, where we are
submitting the user form data,
we're dispatching the
addFormData action.
But let's see, if we copy
that, come back here,
and we search for it, it
doesn't exist anymore, right?
We used to have
addFormData as a reducer
inside of our reducers list,
but we don't have that anymore.
Instead, we have
these extraReducers.
And we don't actually
call these cases.
These are listening to
events from these thunks.
So instead, we're going to
go ahead and call the thunk.
So we're going to want to call--
you can see this
createUser is exported.
That's what we're going to
want to dispatch instead.
So if we go--
I actually already
prompted it here.
I just gave it my
DisplayUserData component,
where I was showing the
list, and my index component,
where I was adding to
the list, and said,
and what other updates
do I need on these files?
So in the index.jsx,
it's just saying, hey,
all you need to do is update
which function you're calling--
or call the thunk
instead of your reducer.
So let's go ahead and do that.
Inside of our index, we're
going to call create--
I already forgot what
I called it exactly,
or what it called it; I
didn't write it-- createUser.
Go ahead and call createUser.
There we go.
And we've got the import.
And as long as we're
giving it the data--
oh, and when I made
this display a list--
when you display a list of items
that have the same structure,
you need to give
them all a unique ID.
So I had given them
that unique ID for now,
while I had a list
render locally.
But our backend is
going to be in charge
of handling unique IDs,
because our backend is
in charge of the database and
the database makes these IDs,
right?
So we're not going to
have the frontend tell
the backend database what
IDs the rows should have.
So the frontend doesn't
need to know about the IDs,
so I'm just going to pass data
to the thunk action there.
And DisplayUserData,
it grabbed a whole--
it wrote some new
code for me here.
And let's walk
through what that is.
So we have our fetchUsers-- oh,
and it pulled in deleteUser too.
Do we have a delete
button on here?
Oh my gosh, it added
a button for us.
I didn't even ask for that.
They're just
proactively helpful.
OK, so what's happened
here is, instead of--
and I don't remember what the
Selector was reading before.
Actually, it might be--
yeah, it's the same.
We're just pulling
state.user data
and pulling the
formDataList out of there.
So we're pulling-- in our
slice, we have this list.
That's what we're pulling
with our useSelector.
So it's reading the data from
our Redux store the same way,
but we've also got this
extra logic right here.
We're dispatching fetchUsers.
And why are we doing that?
So just in case we landed
on this component that
shares the list of
data here, we want
to make sure we pull the
entire list of user data
to display on this page.
So we're going to
dispatch fetchUsers
so that it will call
this fetchUsers thunk
and just pull all the
data-- make a GET request
to pull all the data that
that endpoint exposes.
So now, we have a complete
list of the data here.
And so if we refresh our
app, or we land on the page
and we reload the
page, then it'll
just make a fetch
request to the backend,
to pull the list of data.
And that will
rehydrate this list,
so it won't be empty anymore.
And what is useEffect?
UseEffect, it's a way to
run some logic whenever
certain data in the app changes.
In this case, it is
waiting for dispatch
to change, which I
might ask it about that,
because that doesn't
make any sense to me.
I'm going to not
listen to anything.
So what this is going to
do is when this app mounts,
it will run whatever is inside
of useEffect at least once.
The first time that
this page loads,
we're going to
dispatch fetchUsers.
And then what this little list
down here is supposed to be for,
is anytime data in
this list updates, we
run the contents
of useEffect again.
But I don't really want
to run dispatch fetchUsers
multiple times.
I don't expect the
list of users to change
while I am on this page, unless
I have something to change it.
And I don't do
that on this page.
Though I could
delete it, I guess.
Delete happens but delete
also updates our local copy,
so we don't need to run
this more than once.
So once, when this
page loads, we're
going to dispatch fetchUsers.
If for some reason,
you think you
need to check the user's
data or the list of user data
more than once, you could
put some sort of variable
in here that you listen to.
And when that variable
changes, call fetchUsers again.
But the long story short
is, useEffect just makes it
so this only runs once.
And the UI can still update.
But if this list updates, we're
not going to fetchUsers again.
We're still only going to do
it once, when this page loads.
That all said-- so we
got our slice updated.
It's using extra reducers.
We've got thunks.
We've got the thunks
imported into our components.
So let's go ahead
and give it a shot.
The Metro server
was already running.
But I don't need to restart
it because I haven't
installed any new node modules.
If I open the Network tab
and I refresh this page--
users, and I'm going to say,
this is maybe a CORS error.
So it looks like I
accidentally deleted something
while I had the file open.
You know what a good way to
check for undesired file changes
is?
Check with Git.
OK, it looks like
api urls.py changed.
So Git has ew.as_view.
It's ew.
I'm going to just
undo those changes.
Oh, I had an extra
space in there.
Delete it.
OK, so now, I need
to spin this back up.
And the Metro server
is still running.
So if I refresh this,
users CORS error.
That's what I was looking for.
So what CORS is, is
cross-origin resource sharing.
It's basically
making sure that you
can't pull files or resources
on the same machine,
from the same machine.
And what that does
is it makes it--
it's a way to protect your
computer, your EC2 instance,
or any other machine that
you have a server running.
It helps protect it from
certain types of cyber attacks.
And so what we're going to
need to do to set up Django
to allow CORS-- since we're
running this as a development
server, you wouldn't do this.
In prod, your-- like,
if you were running
an app in production, you would
have your Django server running
on one machine,
at one URL or IP,
and then your app frontend
would be hosted somewhere else,
so you wouldn't
have CORS errors.
But while we do
have this set up,
so that it's running on one
EC2 for dev and for our test
environment, we will want to--
we'll need to
enable CORS headers.
So let's go ahead and do that.
There's a pip install.
And I don't remember what it
is off the top of my head.
So "I am running my
django server and expo app
on the same machine.
Django on port 8000--" it
probably doesn't need to know
what the ports are.
It will want your settings.py
so it has something to edit.
Let's go ahead and
get my settings.py.
My INSTALLED_APPS, it's got
rest_framework, api_app.
We're going to add
another one there--
here, in just a second.
OK, there's the pip install.
And I'm going to modify that a
little bit because we're using--
I believe we have pip3.
Yeah, so instead of--
they gave us pip
install, but we have
pip3 install
django-cors-headers.
And make sure your virtual
environment is active when
you do these pip installs--
pip3 install
django-cors-headers.
I'm going to let that run.
There we go, it's quick.
Then let's see.
The next step is
we'll need to update--
yeah, corsheaders, add that to
our installed apps, right here.
Then we're going to add
CorsMiddleware, just
add that line.
I don't think the
order here matters,
but I'm going to
keep it the same.
And then let's go ahead and set
this environment variable, True.
And I'm just going
to keep this up here,
next to my ALLOWED
HOSTS being anything.
Remember that both of these
things need to change in prod.
Only use in development,
this is very important.
You do not want CORS attacks
on your machine in prod.
Oh, look at that,
CORS_ALLOWED_ORIGINS,
so it's allowing
it from port 8081.
If you know where your requests
are going to come from,
you could do that.
I'm just going to do this for
now in development, though.
Oh, look at that, mobile
devices on the current network.
So if you-- yeah, so if
you've got your mobile app
running-- how thoughtful.
Or you could just
ALLOW_ALL_ORIGINS and not
have to worry about
it while in dev.
And then this, we're not going
to be worried about credentials
yet, but we'll get there.
So I'm going to just put that
in there for now, anyway.
But that, Restart Django
Server, yeah, this
will require a Django restart.
And by my memory, that is
everything that we need.
All right, let's go ahead
and check-- the Metro
is still running, right?
Yep.
Go ahead and refresh that page.
CORS error, again.
I got it figured out, so all
we need to add for a CORS
to allow for our
development environment is
this CORS_ALLOW_ALL_ORIGINS,
True.
Later, if we get
to authentication,
we'll need this,
credentials, True as well,
but not necessarily
necessary right now.
Then in INSTALLED_APPS,
we'll need corsheaders,
which we pip installed.
And then I did check,
the order matters.
CorsMiddleware needs to go
inside of our middleware list
here.
It has to be before
CommonMiddleware,
like I put in the comment here.
And don't worry about
memorizing this.
I will commit this, and
push it to the repo,
and post that repo link,
so that you have it.
You'll have the code
when I post this lecture,
so don't worry about
memorizing that.
You can always look it
up there for reference.
Then the other thing I
forgot-- or not forgot,
I don't know if I knew this.
Maybe I did, and then I forgot.
Django has a strict requirement
for their request URLs.
I had api/users, like this,
with no slash at the end,
and Django doesn't like it.
You have to have a slash
at the end of your URL
or Django will-- it was throwing
a CORS error without the slash,
and I don't know why.
But, yeah, it just threw a
CORS error, of all things.
So make sure you have the
slash at the end of your URL.
And I went ahead and modified
these string compositions.
They used to have
a slash in here,
but since the base URL has the
slash in it, I took that out.
And we've still got the slash
at the end there, after the ID,
for the update and
delete endpoints.
But the GET and POST endpoints,
we'll just use this whole string
with the slash at the end.
Then over here, if we pop
open that page in the app,
and then I hard refresh, now
we are getting-- let's see,
if we go open up the
Network tab, we go to users,
and we can see we're getting
that request coming in, OK.
Request URL is
localhost:8000/api/users/.
Yours will be your EC2 address,
if you're running on EC2.
If you want to debug this on
localhost, that's fine as well.
And our status is
coming back 200.
Anything that starts with
a 2 is generally a success.
In the Response, you can
see the data that I made.
And I made that one, again,
just here with the REST API
endpoint for development.
But let's-- now that
we've got that working,
let's go ahead and try to
add one from our Expo app.
Upload Expo app home page.
I'm just going to
collapse this, actually.
And I'm going to call
myself Expo User.
And I like yellow.
Submit.
Oh, it didn't catch it because
I didn't have DevTools open.
But if we go to
the user page, app,
now we've got the
Django User that I
added from the Django
page, and Expo User
added from our Expo app.
So again, the way that
worked, let's start from--
let's do a run
through from start
to finish of how that worked.
So from our React component,
our index in this case--
it could be whatever component
you have your form in--
we get our user
data from our form.
And I just have it here.
We pass that user data
to our createUser.
And this is no longer a Redux
action, this is a thunk.
We're passing that to
our thunk, but we still
have to dispatch it with
dispatch, which we import
from useDispatch, react-redux.
UseDispatch makes
a dispatch function
that we pass our createUser
thunk with our data to.
That createUser thunk
is inside of our slice
now, which is dispatching--
or it's fetching,
it's creating a fetch
request at our endpoint
here as a POST request.
Remember, a POST request
always include data
that we are sending
in the request.
And that data here
is in the body.
And we're sending JSON data.
So in our headers, Content-Type
is application/json.
Our body has our JSON body.
And you can't just send
the JSON object directly,
you have to send it as a string.
And that has to do
with the way the data
is serialized when it's
passed in the network request.
So at this point, it gets--
the fetch request will push
that data to the backend block.
At this point, this is,
from here on, asynchronous.
So the JavaScript code stops
executing at this point.
It's waiting.
And we go to Django.
So we hit Django
with this URL, OK,
localhost or your EC2 instance.
8000/api/users/, Django
gets this and it's like, OK,
api/users, do I have
anything that can match that?
And then we hit
our Django backend.
Urls.py, the one next
to settings.py, this guy
gets hit first, OK.
So this one says, hey, I've
got this thing called api.
And this API endpoint also
has these added on to it,
api_app.urls.
So we can now open that.
And then we've got this users
endpoint and a users endpoint
with an integer at the end.
Well, api/users is what we've
got, so we've got a match.
Since we've got a match, we're
going to open up this view.
This view will
handle the request.
So let's go ahead and open up
this UserListCreateAPIView.
Over here-- look at that,
UserListCreateAPIView.
And it's made with our
generics from REST framework.
That's basically all
the code that we need.
And REST framework writes
the rest of it for us.
And then we have our Serializer.
We need the serializer because,
remember, in our slice,
we had to stringify this, right?
So it's a string, it's not JSON.
Python-JSON is not the
same as JavaScript-JSON.
So in our view, we've got a
serializer to help handle that.
And Django REST
framework kind of
handles the rest of
the logic for us.
But at the end of the
day, it uses our models.py
to say, hey, have you got
a table for this user?
Yes.
And then we match it up.
The data that we've got gets
matched to these columns.
First_name, last_name,
phone_number, these
are all columns.
They're character fields,
in other words, strings that
match a length of 100 or less.
So if I had submitted some name
with more than 100 characters,
we would see this fail.
We would get a bad request
response from Django.
And then after that, it
gets added to the database,
suppose it gets added to
the database successfully.
Our view, Django REST framework
again handles this for us.
But it just responds,
saying, hey, I got that data,
you get a 200
status, and I'm going
to give you the entire object
you gave me back to you
in response.
So back in our slice, let's
go down to the fulfilled.
Oh, actually, let's handle--
in our createUser
POST, so at this point,
yeah, Django responded to us.
The asynchronous waiting
period here is over.
We've come to the next line now.
If not response.ok-- well,
we did get an OK response,
that data was sent successfully,
and added to the database,
and it gave it back to us.
So we're not throwing
an error here.
But if we got an error, this
is where it would happen.
And then we return
response.json.
So we return whatever
data it gave back to us.
And then that triggers
the fulfilled event, which
is caught by our extraReducers.
So if we go down here to the
createUser.fulfilled event,
then we have an action.
That action.payload is that JSON
that the server gave back to us.
So we add to our existing list
of form users that user that got
returned to us.
So we had a form here.
We pushed the data to Django.
Django responded
with the same data.
So Django got the copy that
got added to the database.
We got a copy.
We added it to our Redux store.
So now, we both have a
copy of the same data.
So that's how it
goes full circle.
I think that handles all of the
requirements for Homework 4.
So yeah, we went from Homework
3 to Homework 4 in one lecture.
It's a lot.
If you need to stop this or
go through it multiple times--
please, please, ask questions
in the teams chats and channel.
We can have an open
discussion there
to follow up with any questions
you may have from this lecture,
or any hiccups that
you come along.
But if I don't hear
from you there,
hope you have a
happy spring break,
and we'll see you
after the break.